being a physicist from all
objective point of views is a miserable
career yes and I don't have to State the
reasons the only reason it's worth doing
is you just enjoy this you're obsessed
by it you love what you're doing
and so if you do it as a job it's going
to be very very disappointing I think so
don't underestimate yourself
until I went on this crazy adventure of
uh Amanda and Ice Cube I always live
with the insecurity that I didn't belong
to the circles I moved in which I think
must be true for almost every graduate
student just get over that
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
well it's not every day you get to talk
to a hero of physics of modern physics
someone whose roots go go back quite a
way someone who's been a leader in the
field of of astrophysics of particle
physics who's an educator and a
communicator of science but also who was
actually I think today's guest is my
first ever guest who is a professor of
mine although I took his class as an
adjunct student while I was at the
University of Wisconsin and it is one of
my personal Heroes this is Francis
halsen uh who is a Belgian particle
physicist although he's been in America
probably more than half his life he's
the Hilldale and Gregory bright
distinguished professor at the
University of Wisconsin-Madison he's a
director of The Institute for elementary
particle physics and he's the principal
investigator of the Ice Cube neutrino
Observatory which is operated at the
South Pole Antarctica since 2010 before
that there was Amanda Francis it's a
certain treat to be here for me to host
you here rather and I just hope you
won't share the grade that I got in your
Club please don't tell my audience
I I don't think my bureaucracy my
Administration is so good that I would
be able to produce it well it was one of
my favorite classes of all time not not
to mention the fact that back then it
was rare that professors wrote The
Textbook that was used for the class I
think I had that only with Leon Cooper
at Brown
um with one of his quantum mechanics
books
um but uh but to take this course on
particle physics with you and it was it
was such a treat and I thought we'd
start there Francis we always start we
have on you know we just had on Martin
Reese Lord Martin Reese last week and he
spoke about his book and we always do a
scenario called judging books by their
covers where we look at the cover of
your book and we judge it and and how
did you come up with the name and
hopefully entice you know a a tenfold
increase in Book Sales instantaneously
so the book we're talking about is
called quarks and leptons it was a
wonderful wonderful book that I had
there we'll show it on the screen it's
written with your co-author Alan Martin
well I don't recall uh much about him
but but certainly taking it from you was
quite a treat so Francis can you help us
judge quarks and leptons by its cover
how'd you come up with the title The
subtitle and the cover illustration the
title was
actually first of all I must say this
was a long time ago
and that's the amazing thing about the
book right
people don't realize now that this book
was written
a long time ago and that the W the Z the
top Quark none of these things the Higgs
none of these things had been discovered
you know like the whole book is kind of
prediction of the standard model
and in fact it I the the book was
imprint when the W was discovered that
sound the weak intermediate bosom wow
and uh so the editor called me and said
you can still change things you know
I've read a newspaper and I said there's
nothing to change
and he was kind of uh worried that he
had been part of some huge Gamble
so
but the title is kind of embarrassing
because although I think it was really
the books were really written in
parallel uh Okun famous
Russian theorists called The Brook
leptons and quarks that came out around
the same time so it's not that original
and the illustration that you have on
the cover what does that represent
there's I
I the only thing I remember is that I
actually made it and it remembers you
know Jets were something rather new then
uh you know core glue on sets the
concept and so I know that it represents
like a jet made in deep inelastic
scattering or something like that right
it's amazing that I cannot remember uh
no I I think that Rings true and
actually we have had on past guest uh
Frank will check uh many times and he he
cites that the discovery of jets at
least not not by you know Ice Cube or
anything personally but he cites that as
as the kind of signature achievement of
of his career and of work that the
particle physics as a community has led
to
um and I wonder you know if we could
pivot from this wonderful book which I
learned a great deal from and I still
make reference from when I have uh the
the task of teaching to young people as
well as well as your style so I want to
first take a step back uh it is rumored
that you knew lemaitre the famous uh
Belgian Catholic priest the progenitor
in some sense of the big bang is that
true Francis I barely knew him uh he uh
he died when I was doing my
undergraduate thesis
and so I could tell a mattress stories
for a long time but I thought I'd tell
you too uh because of course if every
interaction I had to resume is now
legendary Right but I'll only tell you
too he had a computer he built himself
to solve Friedman's equations and it was
a big room with vacuum tubes
and that computer I mean it was state of
the art at the time was only used during
uh the day and we actually we mean the
another graduate student and I have more
gas months we would actually break into
the room and use the computer at night
and we used it to calculate Feynman
diagrams Feldman had just discovered the
methods right to to to to calculate
Feynman diagrams by computer and so I
think we may have been the first people
to do this after Feldman discovered it
the other story is that uh when I
I was
an undergraduate the matter would arrive
in a limousine at the physics building
and you know it was an important person
and he couldn't walk anymore barely walk
and we put him on a chair
and then carried him to his office on
the second floor and it's only later
that someone else who was part of the
Institute told me that that was actually
lumet I had never made the association
wow he was not very visible he was
retired then uh you know he came in very
rarely
and by the way he was not famous right
as you can imagine right he was famous
for uh being a cardinal and for his role
like maybe his whole emphatican too but
I don't think so actually yeah so he was
uh I mean you know the status of
cosmology at that time right
so it was just at the time he died
that's you know when the microwave
background was discovered
that's right and one of the things
that's always impressed me about him and
many others is that he was an advocate
that the pope uh was it Gregory I forget
who it was in Vatican but they they uh
attempted the Vatican attempted to uh
utilize the you know predictions of the
Big Bang at least as a motivation for
Genesis and I was actually just in
Galileo's uh house in in Florence
archetri Italy and of course you know he
was refuted by the the Catholic church
and repudiated his own ideas under
penalty of death basically but um did
you ever get the sense or was there
anything in the Belgian physics
Community perhaps that uh what that that
you know spoke of what was his true you
know um emotional investment in the Big
Bang did he have one or was he able to
detach being a scientist
yeah I cannot tell I was not
you know he I never got any class he
basically was at the end of his life and
so we had really no interactions
scientifically with him but the fact
that he uh
he denied that the Big Bang had any
connections to Creation that's I think
well documented
yeah you read this biograph there are a
couple of biographies of his which I've
read of course and uh uh they they
clearly document that he he didn't see
he didn't make any connection to
religion
and when we were getting ready to start
recording today
um I wanted to kind of get your you know
take on the obligations of a scientist
in terms of what he or she should do
quote unquote should do uh and I think
you know La Matrix certainly took that
role seriously but but you know he had
so many hats that he was wearing you
know pontifical hats maybe and science
hats but um but what's your philosophy
we'll we'll come to more kind of big
picture questions later after we review
ice cube in your career but um what is
your view of what the obligation if any
that a scientist has to explain things
to the public and then do they have to
kind of be careful how they explain
things because maybe the public doesn't
understand what they're doing well I
think I
from this point of view I am a very
practical person I don't think I'm on a
mission of anything
and on the other hand uh I think that uh
even we are supported uh by the public
to do our science we owe some return to
them and you know I have never found an
invitation you to talk about my work to
anyone at any level any student of any
age I always react positively to an
invitation to discuss my work and and
that's I think an obligation we have
uh beyond that uh I think it's very
dangerous to
you know our expertise is science and
it's actually even within science it's a
very limited expertise and I think it's
uh to the advantages of scientists that
they stick to their expertise
and that's certainly something I always
do
yeah I always say that you know the
problem that we are scientists deal with
is that sometimes we become political
scientists and yeah delve into politics
uh no that's not a good idea and it also
it hurts science right because it then
science begin to look like something
that it shouldn't be and it's not
right and there's a danger in what we
call audience capture that you have to
um only do what your audience wants you
to do so on this channel a lot of times
people want me to only have people that
won the Nobel Prize or only talk about
aliens or only talk about dark matter
and I have to be very careful because I
get a lot of attention from the videos
uh that are popular but that isn't
necessarily the totality of what I think
a scientist should be interested in so
anyway I think you're absolutely right
and I want to ask you
um you know first we can go back uh to
maybe a moment in your career that was a
little bit you know maybe perilous I
remember being in Madison as you know
from 97 till uh Peter timby my wonderful
advisor who's been a guest on the
channel so you're my second guest from
the University of Wisconsin-Madison the
great Badgers uh uh cheese State
Dairyland State
um so I had nothing but fond memories of
being there uh when I had Peter on we
were kind of you know speculating on on
the the notion as a scientist to deal
with uncertainty and I remember you
building you preparing to build and
starting to build up Amanda and it
wasn't just the technology it wasn't
just the theory it wasn't just the
science it was the people it was the
team that you built which is you know
which is unrivaled and it seems to me
you've been working on this for so long
was there ever a time that you had
doubts in yourself that the funding
would come about that you might not
succeed as you've done so spectacularly
well uh with Ice Cube did you ever have
a moment of panic uh that you just were
so terrified that project might not move
forward the whole the whole story was a
story of panic you see you you got the
right word
uh you know from the beginning when uh
people taught
that uh this was a very cute idea but
that it wouldn't work
well that's what we told too so but it
kind of started as a
you know was a game it didn't cost that
much we were piggybacking on the on the
South Pole infrastructure that already
existed to a large extent uh but then
NSF uh
started to fund the project I actually
borrowed a lot of money from the
University of Wisconsin
and
I was deep in debt to both NSF and the
university and we had never seen an
adreno not an atmospheric neutrino
and so and of course it's because we
really didn't know whether turning ice
in a shrink of detector was possible it
took us like a decade to figure out what
the ice was like we couldn't put it in a
test Beam at fermilab and so uh you know
the most exciting
among all the Panic moments the most
exciting moment was not when we
discovered Cosmic neutrinos but when we
finally observed atmospheric neutrinos
because that I felt we've delivered now
it's up to Nature
and even afterwards I thought you know
if a scientists in English like to
gamble right scientists wrote an article
that gave us six to one to
discover a cosmic neutrinos
against of course and I remember not
feeling very well when I read this but
then
uh I always told if we did build
something that unusual we'll do
something interesting the big surprise
actually is that we are doing neutrino
astronomy and not something totally
different we do different things as well
but the other moment of panic is when we
finally got the courage to publish in
science that we had detect Cosmic
neutrinos and weeks later we were
declared
breakthrough of the year
in 2013 and I must say that was also a
moment of panic and I remember the press
conference and the only thing I told
about is how do we run this backwards if
this happens not to be true
right and now I lift was that Panic for
quite a long time in fact it's only now
that we see sources right since 2017
that's you know I I I sleep better at
night
well that's a you know 30-year journey
to but this this was a wild ride right
this whole story of ups and downs and
yeah so
um what was the role of the South Pole
in in this it could it have been done
somewhere else there there are
alternative approaches but none even
closely related in success to what
you've achieved so no there that that
was uh it's a unique opportunity because
us you need clear ice clear ice
existence where but you have to build a
sophisticated detector in a remote
location and without a South Pole
stations I mean you this would not have
been possible remember we started in a
very modest way and nobody would say oh
there by we always wanted to build a
kilometer Cube detector can you imagine
someone saying ah
also wants to build a kilometer Cube
detector let's build a station somewhere
above the glacier in Greenland and give
him the opportunity it was pure
Serendipity that these two things came
together the Clear Eyes at the South
Pole and and the station being there
nobody would have built it for us no and
it's such a unique location I've been
there twice uh I I actually prefer going
to McMurdo then going to the South Pole
but that's just me a lot of people love
going to the South Pole more than
anything uh and the the results that
you've garnered yeah it's it's it is
serendipitous in a way but it also took
a lot of foresight by you and your team
to recognize and persuade I I think one
of the least appreciated aspects of a
scientist is his or her ability to
persuade and that includes persuading uh
undergraduate to work in his or her lab
or a funding agency or to get tenure to
get even a professor job is so hard
nowadays but then building a team so
it's it's not enough to have the right
idea like the idea is just kind of the
table Stakes you know to use a gambling
analogy
um so when when did the the kind of um
that that sub subsiding of that Panic
what has been I mean of all the things
that ice cube does and we're going to
cover it a little bit of technical
detail because my audience is the most
sophisticated in the known regions of
the Multiverse that we inhabit but I
want to ask you of of the technical
breakthroughs could Ice Cube have been
done you know 50 years ago let's say if
there was a you know very very young uh
Francis halsen as a graduate student
could you have done it 50 years ago or
were there technological breakthroughs
that you and your colleagues and
understanding of the ice has made yeah
it depends it's a difficult question I
that's a question I've never answered
three years ago uh
one of the challenges I mean maybe the
biggest challenge was to
build a hot water drill
and that was such an unusual problem it
was also an exciting problem because you
know you don't go to school and they
teach you about hot water drills right
no so well in Wisconsin they do actually
right this was done by a group in
Wisconsin
of Engineers professors graduate student
technicians anyone who contr could
contribute contributed and it was very
exciting but I think you know it's Car
Wash heaters that make the power and the
nozzle is very sophisticated it was
designed by an engineer but it could
have done been done before no doubt
about it
I am not so sure about uh the data
acquisition because
of course we could have used the Amanda
technique of of just sending analog
signals over uh the cable that brings
down the high voltage right to that
powers the photo multipliers
so but the
the data acquisition of Ice Cube is a
bit more sophisticated you know we
capture the signals in uh in the eyes
transform them to digital and then
transmit them and so that was the fact
that ships that are used where the PHD
thesis of a student of David Nygren at
Berkeley
so that was really a bit beyond state of
the art at the time of course now uh
that technology is is looks like
archeology right but uh this was uh
the the Berkeley design was made in um
in the late 1990s because it was all in
place when we submitted a proposal in 99
right wow so it could have been done it
probably could have been done earlier
but in its present form and for the
discoveries we make the electronics I
don't think we could have done it with
Amanda analog signals uh uh it's pretty
essential to have the technology that uh
Nikon and the Berkeley group developed
for the data acquisition
I want to ask you because I know you as
a as a student of yours uh albeit not as
a graduate student I think that would be
a great treat but um but as a student in
a class about uh for advanced you know
undergraduates and graduate students on
particle physics
um why do we conflate
um scientific ability with educational
or pedagogy ability in other words
um you know someone who's a pilot may be
extremely skilled at flying but we don't
ask you know him to like teach flying
necessarily although you and you can
actually teach flying with I'm a pilot
in my side hustle uh to to pay the bills
here at the State University of
California but I want to ask you why is
it that we do that do we do they do that
in Europe is that common
um you know that we have an expectation
that because Francis or Brian are good
at scientific research that they're also
good at teaching or
or is that a mistake Well I this is one
this is one of the things I feel
passionately about and never had the
time to do much about it but I think
that uh
you know Dakota uh School
that exists today at the American
universities uh is uh in a sense
unfortunate it still lives in the days
that you take courses and learn all of
physics and then do research
first of all you cannot plan all of
physics anymore you cannot even learn
all about some specialized subject in
physics no so the way I have I I have
everything I know and the Belgian system
at the time allowed you to do this
everything I know I've I've flown by
doing research you get interested in a
problem you have to solve it you learn
everything you need to solve that
problem
and that's how you learn and you
remember by the way and I think
that's the ideal way that you know
trying to get a background of all of
physics before you start doing research
is an illusion
uh which we which we are still living in
in our present system of graduate
schools
yes yes and it's it seems to be you know
sort of strange how the European system
influenced the American system you know
the the Germanic uh kind of uh emphasis
on research and now most of the Ludwig
boltzmann or or Max Max Planck Institute
they don't teach as I understand it so
it's kind of ironic that the educators
of the American system
um they uh they don't do any education
of their own anymore
um so I wanted to talk a little bit
about the technical details and the
theoretical underpinnings of Ice Cube
and and you've been kind enough to
prepare some slides so I'll let you get
set up to share the screen
okay so uh
you know we want to detect uh neutrinos
from space because we want to do
astronomy with neutrinos rather than
with photons and we know how to detect
neutrinos this is an experiment in Japan
in a deep mine and it's a huge tank of
Water and Light sensors
and that's how you detect the neutrinos
the problem with this beautiful
experiment is that the theorists in
their wisdom told us that uh and by the
way I'm not blaming anyone it was one of
them uh told us that this experiment is
ten thousand times too small
to to do astronomy and catch the tiny
flux of uh neutrinos that reaches from
the universe
so
to make a long story short we build a
detector
that uh instead of water made out of
water is made out of ice and the photo
tubes are distributed throughout the ice
and according to
our wisdom as theoristic probably had a
chance to detect Cosmic neutrinos but no
guarantees were given and so what you're
looking at of course is uh
it's not a real picture but so if you go
under the South Pole you stand the South
Pole station stands on three kilometers
of ice and you go one and a half
kilometer deep
there are strings with uh the light
sensors that you saw on the walls of the
Japanese experiment and so these things
are a kilometer long and they are 86 of
them so the light senses between strings
are 17 meters apart and the strings are
uh 125 meters apart and 86 of these
strings feel a volume of ice with uh
light sensors this idea by the way was
uh boom in 1960 the Russian physicist
Markov came up with this idea so the
idea is certainly not new
so the challenge was to
melt this uh sensors into the eyes and
so we developed that was the The First
Big Challenge we developed the
technology at Wisconsin to do this and
the Second Challenge was was this ice
good enough to act as a particle
detector and that's a long story and the
story is told in this slide and I would
spend the rest of your time if I went
through this slide but we made our major
breakthrough when we realized that the
light
blue light in eyes travels over 100 and
sometimes hundredths of meter so this is
uh
compacted snow of 70 000 years ago it's
Ultra Pure and even in a lab you cannot
build a block that transparent to Blue
Light so that we didn't know that that
was pure Serendipity so these two things
being solved we build it into data and
the idea is you can imagine your block
of ice here
and uh
you can imagine that it's like one and a
half kilometer deep it's dark so what we
do is we look for particles coming
through the Earth and only a neutrino
can come through the Earth nothing else
and that neutrino not only comes through
the Earth it comes through your detector
but occasionally like one in a million
will hit the nucleus in the ice
the nucleus of hydrogen or oxygen and
make particles the particles it makes in
the nuclear interaction they are charged
and they make the light glow that's
called shrink of radiation and if this
is a a muon neutrino then it makes a
particle called the muon and it travels
for kilometers in the ice
so that muon you can detect from
50 meters to at high energy 50
kilometers away uh
that's not quite practical but you get
the idea that your detector is is bigger
than what you instrument
and the other thing is you have a
telescope because you not only detect a
muon you can point it back because the
muon travels at the speed of light
almost and the light in in ice travels
at three quarters of the speed of light
so it's like a speedboat that
outruns its waves and so you get a shock
wave
like the bow wave of a boat and you can
and it points back where that muon comes
from and where the neutrino comes from
right so
we built a detector and here you see an
event this is a neutrino that comes 11
degrees below the Horizon and streams
through the detector it deposited inside
the detector
2600 TV of energy
so you must remember the highest energy
Beam at some in Geneva it's 14 TV
so this particle deposit just inside the
detector 2600 and by the way
um
uh I mentioned atmospheric latrinos
which are background this event is much
too heavy to be produced in the
atmosphere much too energetic and we can
do astronomy these days with about 0.3
degree resolution if you didn't get a
picture here you see on a online display
you see the muon going through the
detector with the speed of light slowed
down by the computer
and so that's the method
and so what we did is we
measured neutrinos from the cosmos and
you see here this is the energy
that the detector collected neutrinos
from the cosmos and as a function of the
energy of the neutrinos and the data
points you are looking at are electron
and Tau neutrinos and this actually is
the Flux Of The muon neutrinos measured
the the pink uh
banned is the flux measure is the method
I just displayed the other data points
we measure electron and down neutrinos
with a different method but you see they
agree
and uh so this is the muon flux through
the Earth
and you see how we measure the flux from
the atmosphere when we reach the
threshold of the detector which is 100
GV then we get more and more background
in atmospheric neutrinos and when we
reach some place like tens of TV
then you see the atmosphere turns off
and we see the excess flux that were
shown on the previous picture this is a
measurement now close to 10 Sigma and we
have seen atmospheric neutrinos in at
least four totally different ways
uh that's the status of Ice Cube I have
a few slides to show what our results
are if uh yeah please do please do in
fact one our most important result we
actually never advertise but I'll do
today and I I always personally do
I showed you the flux from that we
received from the universe the energy
flux in neutrinos it's what the
astronomers call new F new
and of course uh we receive we detect
fluxes of gamma rays here you see this
peak this huge Peak that's the CMB
very familiar to my host and then you go
to it dominates the universe then you go
to
uh different wave snakes of light this
is ultraviolet light x-rays gamma rays
but then the universe turns opaque to
gamma rays they turns opaque to gamma
rays because it cannot make they cannot
make their way through the microwave
background
the microwave background filled their
Universe stops them from reaching us
except from the home Galaxy right and
actually uh Francis I have to stop you
there yeah go ahead did you know that
the namesake of your professorship right
the bright wheeler phenomenon which is
the interconversion of photons to to
positron electron pairs that was only
recently detected and um and actually I
made a video about that I'll have a link
to it in here but thank you yeah that
was really exciting right anyway please
go on now the pair production
so these photons uh pair produce make it
plus a minus spares interacting with the
microwave photons and so they loose end
actually so the flux disappears and that
of course is the resonant death of
neutrino astronomy uh you see here once
you are belong Beyond this demarcation
line
you can only do astronomy with neutrinos
and uh but the other interesting thing
is if you look at the flux of the gamma
rays the floxy neutrinos we observe is
actually larger than the fluxing gamma
rays
and nobody had ever expected that and
that's also why we found it with only
two years of data and so this is an
interesting fact which uh still requires
some thought and explanation
uh so
now we have to find where this neutrinos
come from
so here is a picture
of one year of neutrino data in Galactic
coordinates
so that's the sky we see in neutrinos we
have 10 of these pictures for 10 years
of data more now and we know from the
flux we just measured that in this map
there are 138 000 plus atmospheric
neutrinos 200 of them are actually
Cosmic
but you also saw what I explained if you
go to very high energy the atmosphere
cannot deliver neutrinos anymore and you
are in business so if you look at the
very highest energies it look like this
uh these are various methods with which
we collect collect that is Cosmic
neutrinos but notice one thing we don't
see our own Galaxy
now in any other
wavelength of flight or any other way of
doing astronomy the first thing you see
are the sources in your own Galaxy
we don't see those
uh we see flux at the 10 percent level
of the flux that reaches us from the
cosmos
so there are galaxies outside or sources
outside our own Galaxy that overpower
the flux from
the nearby sources that produce
neutrinos in our own Galaxy uh
we have a paper that's on on the review
in science that will address this
question
but just to remind you that's what the
Galaxy look like invisible light and we
don't see uh the galactic plane in
neutrinos now
for many years we made uh
the cosmic neutrinos who have discovered
in 2013 of course the game was where do
this particle come from you know we know
their Direction now to 0.3 degrees
and we did all kind of things
uh but I'm going to just tell you about
the latest we we actually discovered the
source in a multi-messenger campaign in
2017 it was an active Galaxy
and uh
I'm going to tell you what happened uh
since then we collected we looked at our
10-year map and we published a paper a
year ago and you are looking what's in
this paper uh and forget that just look
at the blue
the blue this is uh
the upper limit on neutrino sources we
didn't see any by analyzing 10 years of
data
and you see the dashed line is our
sensitivity to sources as a function of
where they are in the sky the northern
hemisphere is on the right zero is the
Horizon and the left is the southern
hemisphere
and we discovered however that our map
after 10 years was not quite symmetric
isotropic anymore and it was due to
these four sources
that we detected that almost five Sigma
Discovery but that's before the look
elsewhere effect
after he implied to look elsewhere
effect that he has symmetry in the map
was still real but the evidence for the
source is not so great uh NGC 2068
almost reached three sigma these all
trials take into account
so the question was for this limits on
fluctuations and I'm not going to I'll
just give you the answer they are not
fluctuations
uh we went to a campaign to calibrate
the detector better to do improved the
reconstructions using machine language
we improved the point spread function of
the telescope abandoning gaussian
approximations and uh with the
conspiracy of all these improvements we
answered the question I just post and
here you see NGC
uh
1068 before the improvements and then
you see we calibrated the detector
better in including calibrating each uh
foot or tube individually
and you see how
this is the source the astronomical
occasion you see how the with more
statistics we move towards the source we
the we
Point better at the source and our final
evidence is at the level of 4.2 Sigma
now this is uh the result of a blind
analysis where we mathematically can
compute all our trials so this is a real
this is not a social construct it's a
real probability and so I can sleep well
at night with 4.2 Sigma
so here another way of looking at it
this is a picture of NGC 2068 it has
this very active hot uh
Corona surrounding the central black
hole
and here you see the simplest way to
look at a signal you see this is the
direction
of NGC 2068 the
oranges are backhand by atmospherm
atmospheric neutrinos and you see if you
approach the source the number of
neutrinos increases so we see 88
neutrinos pointing at the source with on
average higher energy than the energy of
the background which you cannot see on
this picture
so that was certainly very exciting uh
here you see let me just look at the the
top one
uh these are three analysis that confirm
each other they are slightly different
they actually used assume different
spectral indices but you see here the
five Sigma discovery which I showed
before and you see this is pre-tile you
see NGC sticking out of it you see a
soft T excess of 506. that's the source
we discovered in 2017 because it
produced the neutrino of enormous energy
the telescopes in a multi-messenger
campaign pointed back at this source and
of course PKS 1424 plus 240. so the top
three sources reappear with improved
significant
uh
interestingly one of these sources here
on the fourth row in this analysis is
NGC
4151 so here we are
you know in 1943
see for discovered broad spectral lines
from these two sources published in this
paper so we reproduce these two sources
in neutrinos and now I could go forever
at home forever again but so we just all
these sources are sources that are
actually
active in radio so they have active core
and the core is opaque to gamma ray so
none of the stuff we see is accompanied
by gamma rays the gamma rays are shifted
in the dense Target that produces the
neutrinos they are shifted to Mev energy
x-ray or below
and so this is where we stand so in fact
this is multi-messions or astronomy Plan
B how do you look for sources that don't
emit gamma rays that's not so simple
actually so I'm waiting for ideas yeah I
think that's the end of this yes so this
is a
NASA picture of
NGC 2068 yeah sorry this is it
and uh thank you so much uh Francis so
um the other thing I wanted to Pivot to
was a uh recent paper that your team had
in nature about a limit on quantum
gravity and I wonder first of all do you
have any slides about that and it's yes
I do okay great I do and I you don't
I want to emphasize that uh
we are about 350 people analyzing Ice
Cube data the what I presented the
astronomy I presented is probably only
about one third officer doing this I
don't know the exact number but uh
people are using this detector of course
to do glaciology there was a time in my
life I published more glaciology papers
than uh then physics papers I'm very
proud of it and uh the last fraction is
looking for dark matter
that has been a long haul
Amanda's was actually originally very
much motivated by the fact that we would
have discovered dark matter if the wimp
Miracle had happened
and unfortunately it didn't yeah so
that's right but we are still looking
yeah and
people use the neutrinos to do
tomography of the earth geology and it
goes on and on we do neutrino
oscillations competing with fermilab uh
with a different part of the detector
that I didn't emphasize here
but uh one of the things we all we have
been doing is given the opportunities so
unique we have been looking for quantum
gravity
and this is a very old story
there is actually a whole community in
physics that uh involves uh
looking for quantum gravity which is
kind of con Merit to the alternative
which is looking for
violations of special relativity it's uh
it's it's they are uh embed together as
you will see
but
it's easy to explain you know arnotrinos
ever Mars
we detect them over
Cosmic distances
with enormous energies compared to
neutrinos we may get accelerators so the
fact that they have this tiny masses is
very important for physics but it's
totally relevant here the Argentinos are
like photons
and so if they they travel through
tobacco from the source as far away to
here
and even though they have a flavor and
oscillating to each other
by the time they arrive here they arrive
as packages of electron Tau and
munetrinos was equal in equal numbers so
this is boring
unless
this thing happens and I wrote an
article of two decades ago and a German
artist made this picture
and what does it show well it shows what
the vacuum that are neutrinos travel
through looks like
if you marry quantum mechanics and
gravity
and so if you meant America quantum
gravity in
um quantum mechanics and gravity you
know the sheet that matter transforms
that wheeler always talks about that
sheet now has Quantum fluctuations yes
and so this is a picture of what the
vacuum looks like our daily Factor we
live in now uh what it looks like uh
when uh it has Quantum properties and
Quantum fluctuation which it has does
have to have the problem is that in a
preferent vacuum we live in they are
suppressed by the Planck scale so
they're tiny and if I transform the
Planck scale in a distance there's 10 to
the minus 33 centimeters
so you need
neutrinos or photons with wavelengths of
that magnitude
to
become sensitive to these fluctuations
and we do
and we already were aware of this and
set the first limits with Amanda
I don't know if you we want to go into
that much detail but we should yeah I
mean the audience loves to hear the
details you all you how do we look for
this I mean clearly our experiment
is is ideal to look at these particles
traveling through this this Quantum
fluctuations of cosmic distances that's
how we get sensitivity this is fact is
very small but we can build it up by
having the neutrinos travel for a very
long way
and so what you basically do is uh
you test whether the particle satisfied
this the classic special relativity
dispersion relation e Square equal p
squared plus M Square
and that's the property of these
neutrinos when they travel through in
absence through to just vacuum the M
squared doesn't really matter at our
energy
but
this relation between energy and
momentum is modified when the
neutrinos start to interact with they
start to feel this Quantum fluctuation
and that we parametrize as a power
series
you know a sum of N equal one two three
and so on uh
a distortion in energy that's
characteristic of the Planck scale so
the quantum gravity scale or the scale
of the violation of relativity because
you see e Square not equal to P Square
can also be caused by violating special
relativity so we we look for terms like
that when the neutrinos propagate
and so
it's a fuel line calculation so what
what actually happens what happens is
that uh
particles with different energy
now begin to propagate
violating to a different extent is equal
e-square equal p square
relation and so the particles
with high energy get a time delay
uh proportion to particles with slower
energy the ones with high energy
interact more so they get delayed and
the time delay is given by the power of
the term you're investigating this power
series uh you know we typically look for
uh n equal to term
and then so we look for a term uh of
time delays that are proportional to the
energy Square
and so but the time delay builds up the
larger distance you look to the source
so even though this is very small effect
if you build it up over long enough
distances you can can become observable
and it does in the case of Ice Cube
so as I it says here integrate over a
very long distances so here is an
example of one version of this analysis
and I always like to quote to show it
with a quote from Michael Turner who
said they don't like Newtonian physics
general relativity will not last 200
years so we're trying to prove him right
but you see here we can put
limits of Delta C over C A change in
speed of light or an influence of the
gravitational field Phi on the
propagation of the neutrinos and you see
we sensitive to the variation of order
10 to the minus 28
when the coupling to the gravitational
field is strong enough it's given by
this angle which is I won't explain so
you better so we are putting limits on
violations of Relativity of 10 to the
minus 28. now if you listen to How to
how I explained this
so you have these wave packages of three
flavors
traveling through this Quantum
fluctuations
so
the different flavors can go undergo a
phase shift
when they interact with this
gravitational fluctuations and that
creates uh flavor oscillations
made by the interaction with the with
this field with this quantized field and
that violates can violate the prediction
I made two minutes ago that we have wave
package of equal flavor arriving
and so what Ice Cube now does is uh it
uh
and that the paper we recently published
was one version of this so this is uh
the number of uh Tau mu and electron
neutrinos in the beam so we have to
discover this Red Dot
if we are anywhere else in this plot we
have discovered something Lorenz
violation quantum gravity and you cannot
interpret it any way you want and so our
present this uh this Red Dot
with our present measurements of the
three flavor scenario as a systematic
error which is given by this uh
by this butterfly but so if we we can
establish
uh violations of these principles new
new physics uh by ending up somewhere
anywhere else in this diagram and so
this is a present measurement
this is the error bar at a 68 level and
we are doing a dedicated effort similar
to or even bigger to what I explained
for finding the sources of the cosmic
neutrinos to squeeze this error bars we
are actually going to put in
uh new strings upgrading the detector in
the season 20
5 26 which among other things will
exactly focus on making these smaller
lips around the Red Dot and hopefully
maybe not so we will see but this is a
high priority of the experiment I have
two more slides to to remind you of
uh
a fun fact you
may remember that the Opera experiment
discovered the violation of Relativity
many years ago yeah it was actually the
year before the bicep 2 results came out
which made us very nervous that we made
a plunder
yeah exactly and uh you can see on this
slide there is another way to test
relativity which postponed out by glass
show
that is if uh your particles move at a
speed of light C Prime which is bigger
than the speed of light
they carry an excess energy MC Times
Square minus m c square and that explain
actually they can radiate away
and uh that radiation for instance can
be come out as a plus a minus pairs but
when they radiate away their energy it
means they lose energy and at the time
glassro and and Floyd Stecker pointed
out that the highest standards in
neutrinos had actually too high energy
and were inconsistent with the Opera
observation
of course I don't know whether the Opera
has observation disappeared before the
paper was published but our highest
energy events seen at the time were
inconsistent with that violation of
collativity so it shows we are doing
something real in in a very concrete uh
way right uh actually yes I didn't know
about that and Sheldon Sheldon was a
guest on the podcast about two years ago
and I neglected to ask him about that
event well there's so much to talk to
Sheldon about as there is yeah I mean
how do you pick your subjects right yeah
we could go for hours the only thing I
want to say about the Lorenzen variants
and we're looking for it in the uh
polarization signals of distant objects
as they rotate or do not rotate and you
can look for uh birefringence types of
facts as you talked about with the Eyes
by the way did you you know it's a clear
Quantum but what what I was explaining
before is the analogous of gamma-rays
traveling to a crystal right and they
can exchange their polarizations there
so it's a pure Quantum effect but it's
it's very straightforward to to look for
it
yeah it's uh very interesting and I
guess the only you know kind of um uh
you know critique that I've heard is
that the results are somewhat model
dependent I mean this this SME framework
which I've used in my papers before as
well yeah it's very
um it's it's very specific to a
particular class of you know it's like
they say about non-gaussianity it's like
saying it's a non-dog animal well
there's a lot of non-dog animals in the
world right so how do you address those
you know well my answer is that uh
this is the least model dependent you
can get right if you have a model you
can always reinterpret it in terms of
this power expansion that's right this
is actually a standard method that was
pioneered by Weinberg right to to do you
have a theory and you parametrize the
deviations in terms of operators with of
different dimensions and enter the
dimension of these operators
that's amazing yeah so I think that's
the most model so it's the most model
independent you can can get that and any
model we can reinterpret in terms of
these results that's right that's right
um well thank you so much for that
Francis I guess the um the topics I now
like to turn to is uh what comes next uh
for Ice Cube there's rumors of advanced
Ice Cube um structure that will come
about can you talk a little bit about
the status of do you have any size on
that or or no uh I uh I talked to have
any slides sometimes that's fine yeah so
I
but it's very simple I mean
if I had given a one-hour talk and I I
often do on my scoop
the only conclusion any reasonable
listener can come to is we need better
angle resolution we need more statistics
we just don't want to deal with a few
sources we need more sources and what do
you do you have to build a bigger
detector yes fortunately
we discovered when we build and design
when we build Ice Cube
we only had uh
fake understanding of how large the
absorption length actually was because
Amanda was much smaller right so we had
never seen ice and light propagating
eyes over kilometer distance which was
necessary to measure an absorption
length which at the bottom of the
detector is 250 meter for shrink of
light so it's just incredible and uh so
we were conservative but now we know we
can
space are photo multipliers Factor
and so this 125 meter distance between
strings of
Auto multipliers we're going to increase
to 250 meters and then we can instrument
8 to 10 times the volume with the same
number of photomultipliers wow
so 10 times the volume for the price of
uh
I scoop
and of course you know all the
the
data acquisition which I discussed at
the beginning all that is uh improved
and uh much cheaper and so we really
think we can build it next Generation
detector for the same cost as as the
original one we actually have all we
have designed this detector uh and
submitted the design to the decadal
review who endorsed it
so it's not a dream anymore you know and
actually at least unlike the first
stream at this point we know what we're
doing it's not a gamble anymore yeah
that's wonderful well congratulations
with that and of course you know it's
just a phenomenal treat to see not only
the success of your projects and uh the
leaders under your leadership but all
the young people that have come out of
it uh my friend Nathan Whitehorn at UCLA
and and of course sharing the the space
with you and and your team down at the
South Pole
um with uh uh uh so many young people
it's always so energizing to be down
there and not to mention the hot tubs uh
which were which were quite great I
never got to go swimming in one of the
hot tubs yeah I I always show a picture
of the collaboration at the end of my
talk yeah but it's actually a picture
and it's incredible
the age of our collaboration
I have theories why this is but I won't
go into it it doesn't matter the other
thing I have to say is and this was
always emphasized
by the late Trevor weeks who discovered
who who developed uh gamma ray astronomy
earth-based gamma ray astronomy travel
weeks used to say astronomy is not like
particle physics you need many
telescopes
it's not like discovering the Hicks you
know principle one detector could maybe
have done it but you need to even there
you need to and so astronomy the sky is
Big there are many problems with a
smaller telescope and the right idea you
can contribute and so people picked I
think the the the biggest compliment to
Ice Cube is that people are now Planning
and Building detectors building in Lake
Baikal building in the Mediterranean
building in off the coast of Vancouver
in Canada and planning a detector in uh
in China yeah so there are many and many
more to call My Hope
it's truly uh breathtaking and inspiring
to me as one of the uh five or so
co-leaders of the Simon's Observatory uh
which is equally sized and is also
hoping to shed some light no pun
intended on neutrinos and uh they're all
this dark matter and and as uh uh a very
important budget uh and energy budget
constituent in the cosmos so Francis we
speak we speak a lot on this channel to
young people graduate students post-docs
undergraduates and uh one of the
favorite parts of the show is when I
asked kind of non-scientific questions
which I call the existential questions
are the final four and I'd be honored if
you'd answer uh some of them if if you
don't mind right now I am Fearless but I
am I'm probably not a good or certainly
not a typical subject for this but let's
go there's no difficult subject so yes
let's go into the impossible the final
four questions I ask so they typically
quickly have to do with the distant
future of both yourself and and of
humanity perhaps and then advice to your
former self as a young person because as
I said we have a lot of uh mostly men
I'm trying to boost that up but mostly
young men interested in science
technology but we are we are open for
all so the very first question that I
always ask is what would you put in
what's called your ethical will
[Music]
in other words what would you like to to
impart as wisdom that you've learned not
scientific necessarily it could be
anything it could be to your children or
great you know grandchildren or many
many generations down the line what
piece of wisdom guides you if any
well I I think with the advantage of not
just looking at a future but looking
back uh I want to come back to my years
that I was at the mattress Institute
writing my undergraduate thesis on
quarks
and imagine this was 19
67-8
1967 actually uh and uh
so
I alluded to the fact that if you worked
on
cosmology at the time you were kind of a
crackpot right yes the matter was not a
famous person except for the fact it was
a cardinal and he had been uh you know
the president of the papal Academy and
so
uh but
I actually my undergraduate thesis was
on quarks another topic that nobody
would touch at the time right
and so first of all the the first
message is just do what you're
interested in you cannot be successful
if you do physics as a job and I I'm
kind of
at the edge of the generation where
actually physics wasn't a job
and that was wonderful
I'm afraid to say the time is go and
it's rightly gone yeah but uh so that's
one message the other message is
how to you know I don't have to predict
or be efficient okay look how exciting
science is can you imagine that in 67
you worked on quarks and jets and uh on
uh cosmology and the big bang you were
not taken seriously in fact you couldn't
get a job even if it was a job
and uh look where we are now I mean the
a black hole
and the big bang and a quark Setter as
real as this cup of coffee on my desk
right nobody questions this anymore and
this happens in my career in in one
generation of
of a physicist and I have no doubt that
this will continue
it may not continue in the direction
that we are now talking about it may be
often a different direction but I'm sure
it will continue sales will always be
exciting yes absolutely it's the it's uh
as you'll hear in just a second I'll say
what uh the next my next quote comes
from Sir Arthur C Clarke who said that
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic uh and I
want to ask you what knowledge either
from your personal career
or from all of science or maybe I don't
know anything from philosophy theology
who knows what piece of of one sentence
or the shortest amount of words that you
could possibly describe the thing that
Humanity should be most proud of
[Music]
well I as I always limit myself to the
expertise I have
and uh not just Humanity My Generation
should be proud of what we just talked
about and that's something to be very
proud of I think
I agree yeah my late great colleague
Hans Parr did you ever know Hans did you
yes yes so he was uh he was a great
influence on me he said that uh the
general relativity which is part of some
of what we've talked about uh was the
Pinnacle not of just science but of all
of Western civilization
and so I agree a lot had to go into that
you had to have a cooperation language
there's a beauty there's Artistry and
there's also a hard technology and the
most important thing which you keep
emphasizing so rightfully is people and
the culture of an experiment is so
important okay and and people who are
really obsessed with what they're doing
those are the ones you are looking for
that's right yeah
um next question before the second to
last question is another quote from Sir
Arthur C Clarke and he said when a
distinguished but elderly scientist says
that something is possible he is almost
certainly right but when he States
something is impossible people he is
probably wrong so I want to ask you for
instance what have you been wrong about
if anything
[Music]
oh man many things uh in fact uh let's
go back to my my career career was half
uh
Astro particle physics and half particle
physics right I lived
around accelerators and uh
Idaho when
we were writing Halton and Martin uh I I
actually gave Halton and Martin
originated because I took a semester
leave at the University of Hawaii
because I was working with uh Sandeep
pakvasa
by the way that was the time they were
developing Dumont and I had no idea what
Dumont was but I'm sure it's stuck in my
brain somewhere
but at the time they asked me to give a
course and they say you just come and
talk what you did last week
and I thought
I walked into the room and the whole
faculty showed up wow and so
I decided the the set the c0 had just
been discovered the weak intermediate
boson and I talked the first lecture
about what a breakthrough this was and
and so then I actually decided over the
semester to
to develop what we now recognize as the
standard model as lectures and so that
was the beginning of thousand and mark
them uh
so
I think
I never there's something called the gym
mechanism
and I couldn't believe that you could
just invent another quark
to fix a deep problem of the theory and
I thought that was incredibly naive
and it turned out to be right and I
remember going through this history
of me being wrong not believing the gym
mechanism you know the gym mechanism
fixes standard model with postulating
that there there was a charm Quark in
the theory right and so
it made a big impression on me in the
sense that uh
you know sometimes seem you you
shouldn't hold it against simple ideas
you
it's a simpler an idea the more elegant
this was in a sense elegant and I I my
my reaction was totally wrong that
something simple cannot be right in
nature that's simple and so I learned a
lot from that it made a big impression
on me too because uh you know I
I uh
it doesn't feel good being totally wrong
about something no absolutely not but I
think the mark of a good scientist is to
recognize learn from it yeah own up and
I I learned my lesson from that
absolutely and I you know I never have
uh unless something comes is
demonstrably wrong I have very I accept
everything basically I mean if uh you
you have to have a very open mind when
you approach a problem it's not good to
be biased that's what the thing I
learned here yeah well that really does
dovetail into the last question which is
uh from Arthur C Clarke's Third Law
which states the only way of discovering
the limits of the possible is to venture
a little way into the impossible and
maybe I'll pivot because you've said so
much about you know kind of advice to
your former self maybe if you were
getting into this career or in any kind
of career you're 20 years old you're at
the University of Wisconsin-Madison
you're at UC San Diego or wherever now
what would you go into what would you
advise a young Francis halsen to go go
and do to do as you've done to go into
the impossible
[Music]
I'll already gave the answer to that you
go what your interested in unless you're
obsessed by the subject I mean
being a physicist
from all
objective point of views it's a
miserable career yes and I don't have to
State the reasons the only reason it's
worth doing is you just enjoy this
you're obsessed by it you love what
you're doing
and so if you do it as a job it's going
to be very very disappointing I think so
I I think this this is just and
the other thing is uh
you know I always lived
with uh
don't underestimate yourself
I totally lived with until I went on
this crazy adventure of uh Amanda and
Ice Cube I always live with the
insecurity that I didn't belong to the
circles I moved in
which I think must be true for almost
every graduate student just get over
that
and uh I don't know how to do design
effort it until you know you go on a
on a wild ride like we did with neutrino
astronomy then you just you know
surfing the waves right but at many
times of my career I think I missed
opportunities because I was insecure and
uh so you know it are not always the
smart people who make the breakthroughs
that's another way that's a very
parochial way of thinking about it wow
you know imagination can Trump
intelligence that there are many angles
to doing research
and so just go for it
it's a very very uh wonderful that you
say that and we'll close with this um so
when I interviewed Barry barish two or
three years ago now for this podcast I
asked him that same kind of a question
uh in the form of have you ever
experienced The Imposter syndrome which
is this feeling of insecurity that you
just spoke about and he said um uh yes I
have it worse than ever now yeah what
are you talking about you have the Nobel
Prize he said no no Brian when you win a
Nobel Prize you have to uh go and sign
this log book in Sweden that says that I
got my Nobel Prize so Barry's incredibly
curious very imaginative and he goes
back and he looks through the previous
pages and he sees he sees Feynman and he
sees a girl man at his uh Alma at his
home institution of Caltech and he goes
farther back he sees uh Maria Gephart
Mayer maybe here at San Diego and then
he goes back to 1922 and sees Albert
Einstein he sees this guy's signature
here my favorite little sock puppet and
he says I'm not worthy I'm not as smart
as Einstein and I say Barry guess what
you know Einstein had the Imposter
syndrome you know he wasn't always
Einstein said what are you talking about
he said Einstein felt that Newton did
more for the human culture and
civilization than any person before or
since and he said wow I didn't know that
I said Barry guess what it gets better
Newton had the Imposter syndrome he's
like ah you got to be kidding me I said
no Barry Isaac Newton wrote uh he said I
live in shame that I never lived up to
the ideals of Jesus Christ
so we all have our imposter you know
kind of moments when we feel we're
inadequate and then and then he ended up
uh writing I don't know if you can read
this but I'll send you a copy of this
book uh next time I'm out there but
Barry wrote the uh forward to my second
book which has his interviews in it and
I hope someday I I actually read it
either on your web page or somewhere
yeah yes yes I don't think it's unusual
I think it's also I don't think it's a
problem it's only a problem what it
prevents you
from doing things that's right that's
exactly right and I think you're right
to have the courage and just as you said
just do it well Francis you've been an
inspiration to me as a scientist as a
teacher as a leader and as an author and
I'm just so glad and honored and
thrilled that you were able to spend so
much of your valuable time with us thank
you so much I hope we can see each other
again maybe you'll come here in January
and I'll go there in June and we'll go
and get some cheese curds on the capitol
together
it was a pleasure
foreign
[Music]
[Music]